pittsburgh buffalo detroit the middle
class famous tour is coming your way
little mix of stand-up comedy play a
little ayg with the crowd it's going to
be a good time yeah guys get the homies
come out it's a good way to introduce
them to the show we're going to be in
buffalo on june 14th we're going to be
in pittsburgh on june 15th in detroit
june 16th get those tickets we'll see
you there yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they're good to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here at auntie's
basement she's upstairs with the
exterminator swears she has bugs okay i
think she's just detoxing all right
we're gonna see what happens my co-host
is coming at you unamused this week i'm
striking out
he's the ceo of are you garbage
international businessman and he is not
to be trifled with before he has had his
breakfast give it up for kj kevin james
ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true
cooking and then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com and check it the [ __ ]
out gang do it we love it having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up dudes
hey t-bone i'm excited we got the
sandwich man and he got some of the best
looking sandals on the eastern seaboard
come down smell the cold cuts from here
i'll tell you that i thought he'd come
in with a little bit of a party train
but he iced us
but either way again we could not be
more excited to have our incredibly
special guest back with us again today
in studio for the first time in studio
for the first time of course you can
hear him on tastebuds every week with
salvolcano he is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian actor
podcaster and as the long hair said the
new sandwich king of [ __ ] new york
city go down there and check out that
joey rose's you want a nice sandwich a
nice cocktail you get a little taste of
philly right here in new york city and
he's got some live dates coming up he
got july 9th he's going to be in
fairfield connecticut then the 14th and
16th he's going to be out there in san
francisco at the punch line august 12th
and 13th he's going to be in atlantic
city new jersey on september 13th
september 12th i apologize he's going to
be in somerville and the pre-sale is on
right now use code
cb26 ladies and gentlemen of course
we're not talking about r2d2 we're
talking about joey rose's joe derosa
everybody hey how are you tickets by the
way you can buy tickets at joe
doradorosa.com no no no no no jodarossa
info.com joedorosainfo.com i just
realized i want to have joederosa.com
somebody had it yeah i realized we were
giving out codes and i was like they
don't know where they don't know where
to get codes
just google it [ __ ] yeah i like how i
got through the whole thing he's like
you forgot the website no no you didn't
i forgot to tell you to say the website
sorry buddy congratulations thanks on
the shop thanks a lot i'm excited thanks
a lot i appreciate it thank you do you
when you go in there uh-huh are you not
making the sandwiches right no no no if
you go in i did in the beginning of
course yeah if you go in there right now
uh-huh would you and you wanted a
sandwich would you have them make it or
would you walk back and make it yourself
if the if i was alone i actually
probably just had the guy make it
because we it's a one-man kitchen we
don't have it you know and i'm probably
more i'm going to make i'm going to make
it worse by going back there sure yeah
you know what i mean he's back there
he's sanitized
let's do it to the protocol what about a
cocktail will you make your own cocktail
in there sometimes i'll jump back you'll
go back behind the bar grab a bottle
really yeah that's what i'm saying
sometimes
you know uh sometimes yeah and sometimes
when i'm hanging out in there i man the
bar for a minute if the bartender has to
run and grab something nice uh and i
used to when we first opened i used to
bartend shifts okay which i liked yeah
but once it became a real operating bar
uh-huh i couldn't do it sure not i was
not equipped getting in the weeds and
stuff yeah yeah but like in the
beginning when it was just kind of like
people coming in slowly you know it was
all very basic i i enjoyed that quite a
bit have you ever gone there after hours
when it's closed down just to grab
something to eat go in there and make a
sandwich and go home
no
what's the point of having a restaurant
if you don't go in in the middle of the
night and eat four sandwiches you got to
understand that's that's
awful yeah i know it's like no but i
mean like it sounds like oh it's a
hookup it's not it's your place like
that means you then have to clean
everything up
otherwise it's coming with all this
right now i'll just go to the deli yeah
you drink those
drink uh
now i've never done it with a drink
either like i guess i i should i guess
i'd be allowed to go in to my own bar
after hours and have a drink yeah
i'm having a cigarette like casablanca
yeah yeah there you go there you go i
fell asleep sitting at the bar at new
year's and was sent home sent home from
your own establishment
yeah yeah get that bum sleeping at the
corner out of here yeah it's awesome
are people hitting you up now like you
say you go back to philly you go home
see friends or whatever are they
expecting a tray
no no us when i go home sometimes my mom
and dad will say bring some sandwiches
so okay you know i grab a few or
whatever but but usually no charge at
full price
yeah yeah you'd be surprised most people
um
almost everybody i know
uh when they even like they'll come in
and the first thing they say is is i'm
paying don't
you know they're very sure
they want to pay they want to they don't
even make it assume like they don't even
want to have it be a question yeah yeah
i've had a couple on the arm situations
don't worry i got it well we're we're uh
we're uh we try to do we're the type of
bar we try to do a buy back for our you
know guy's been sitting there for a few
years it's big with us a nice buy-back
not a buy-back sandwich but a bubble
drink
yeah and our prices are three heroes
already where's the four
yeah asking if you got a punch card
exactly what are we doing the guy's in
the face on his side is sleeping at the
bar
well let me see let me tell you this
um
the comedy community obviously but so
many people i know that come into the
city for a show
what are you doing before what are you
doing after we're going down to joey
roses and we're trying to sandwich it's
a [ __ ] smash there's a buzz baby it's
wild uh i i owe the comedy community
both performers and fans
and
and not just performers and fans you
know agents and managers and producers
but you're making a superior product you
know people like it and uh yeah it
really is you know people come in and
support i'm i'm so touched by it man
well here's nothing but good things this
might be a controversial statement now
you and i are from even a closer
proximity than kevin and i you're from
montgomery county as well yeah and i'll
say this
and this isn't biased all right i've
eaten a good amount over the country the
suburban philadelphia sandwich
is pretty [ __ ]
top-notch i say so there's more places
down there to get it to get a good
sandwich than there are new york city
and having joey roses i think is a
[ __ ] smash hit thanks man no i i i
you know i try to keep that spirit alive
you know we have we have our core eight
sandwiches which is the hard eight it's
called it's eight sandwiches they're
eight bucks a piece that's the menu we
started with portable
that's one of the reasons
buybacks on sure yeah two for 15 you get
sandwiches down here uh yeah i think
there's combo deals he's [ __ ] making
up deals that joey's got
him joey's got to stand behind no i
think that is the combat dude
trust me i know i was studying the men
yeah yeah 400 pound guys eat free right
yeah yeah
yeah in fact the eight sandwich tray if
you get all eight is sixty dollars
versus six days so that's still
discounted they are saving
[Music]
that core menu is very very true to the
the philadelphia area 100 and what i
grew up with um
and there's some other things that are
coming
soon that are also nods to philly nice
uh but we have a couple new things that
get a little
farther away it's still under our arms
sure we get a little farther away from
the traditional thing because i want the
guy you know we have great guys in our
kitchen i want them to they put stuff
together i want them to be able to have
a little excellent creativity yeah yeah
were you a uh
the peanut butter and jelly were you
always chips when you were a kid
did you put chips on it when you were a
kid honestly you know what you know what
made me start doing that
was uh
my friend bobby when i was growing up
went through this kid great childhood
friend name yeah i know bobby he's the
man do you really bobby is related to me
by marriage are you serious yeah so do
you know that whole clan i mean because
that's a clan i know that whole squad
yeah his dad was my uh cyo basketball
fighters dad's the man
his chat
we'll be back later folks
wow
that's so wild i got to tell him about
this later
i'm still in touch with bob in fact his
sister um kim
uh came to the lesson was in philly she
came to the show fantastic she's
wonderful um so but anyway
so bob when i when we were in college
his summer job one year he was cutting
he was cutting the lawn at the church
okay his neighborhood that was his gig
it was a killer gig
uh and uh it was it's just one of those
killers 401k
it was just
it was just all he had to do was go sit
and cut grass riding mower yeah they
were all by himself that was his only
job i'm with you every day i was like
this is a steal dude like what a gig but
anyway
i just remember that summer he kept
telling me like
for some whatever reason we'd always say
well would you have for lunch and he
kept saying for like this one week every
day he's like i did peanut butter and
jelly chips again
and i kept being like why dude you could
go get a cheesesteak or whatever and he
was like i'm telling you dude it's
awesome it's awesome so then i tried it
and i was like you're right dude it is
good but i still wasn't convinced it was
a lunchtime food
and then when i was in my 20s
i saw a dane
i was i was watching dane cook
and he said
he had a bit where the bit wasn't about
this but in the bit he goes he goes i go
into the kitchen i make a pb and j with
potato chips and a crystal light delish
right yeah
it's all right and i was like and it
reminded me of bob and i was like
oh yeah the chips and the pb and j and
then i started doing it again and that's
when i started to be like no this is a
meal
and then i started to crave it and i
would do it and then i just started to
cut the middle man and put the chips
directly onto the pb and j and that's
when i was like oh this is like
crunch it's a yeah run the salty and the
sweet you put chips on everything like
on mo on a lot of sandwiches no making
like a turkey and cheese at the house
i'm saying like at the house yeah we
have two or three at this shop that have
chips on them at home
sometimes i was always big on putting
chips onto ham and cheese of course i
love it um uh
that was my big one i liked putting
chips on ham and cheese and i like
putting chips i like putting chips on
and then sometimes bologna and cheese i
don't hate it yeah but
but not everything no are you a scrapple
guy a little deep
love scrapple uh i've i i hope one day
we have breakfast hours at the shop
because i want to scrap i want to bring
scrapple into the mix it's funny you
mention that because i was also thinking
pre-broadcast
that it might be time for scrapple to
make its appearance in lunch sandwiches
now well i know this is crazy but i want
to introduce evidence a
which would be the bar
i feel like i'm in a think tank right
now which would be which would be
a barn me sandwich
the vietnamese sandwich what has the
smear pat day rosa not on not on board
oh oh oh it has a smear pate on it you
can get away with doing something with
with the smear but you don't want to put
the pickled vegetables on it do you no
i'm not saying that okay so or maybe i'm
an american
my buddy jordan today
i'm a red-blooded american all right
these colors don't run my buddy jordan
who shot a lot of our promo stuff um
uh
he
wanted he wanted was pushing me into a
scrapple sandwich
and he i said no because i was like we
only do cold sandwiches and uh he was
like we'll do a cold scrub i was like
that's disgusting the seriousness of
this is awesome yeah yeah i feel like
i'm on larry king you should be smoking
right now i just pictured it in black
and white like a remit reenactment we
only do gold sandwiches but i would
consider making scrapple the one hot
sandwich on the menu there you go yeah
yeah i'm with him yeah but anyway it's
fantastic man that's the thought are you
still in the same place you were when uh
when we last talked or did you get a did
you get a new apartment you get an
apartment above the above the shop did
you that'd be no i'm walking distance
though uh which is nice uh almost you
know
uh no uh i don't remember when we last
talked it was a while ago
you were bringing up a vid you you were
bringing up an arcade machine to the
apartment
are you still in that same apartment
that might have been in brooklyn
no no when you guys were at gas i came
in
we did the show
remotely yeah we did it remotely we did
it remotely
i was it was harder the pandemic i
believe
but i was bringing an arcade machine in
or out no maybe maybe one didn't fit or
something there was a lot of video games
in this apartment is that still the case
well that's every apartment i ever live
in really i feel like i was in the place
i'm in now okay if you saw video games
behind me on a shelf then that was my
place i'm in yes yeah yes
there you go okay all right all right i
got a lot of video games and where did
you go to college kutztown university oh
i applied there i almost went there
actually you're not getting it no i got
it i got it right i didn't get it
somewhere else i went because nobody
else took me yeah i don't have the steps
at the interview i got accepted to
temple late in the game okay and i was
like i think i already sent my deposit
to kutztown and then i got temple and
i'm like [ __ ] out i'm going i went to
temple and switched to kutztown
wow look at that the summer me and were
you were you a good student in high
school uh i was a gpa i was a very good
student uh not for the first uh couple
of years but then i pulled it out and uh
yeah i i graduated with a three-point
whatever i graduated college i think
with a 3.4 that's good what was the sats
you remember
terrible yeah very low
very low 980 wow i think maybe i might
have popped that's down the table i
think i might have shaved up around 1100
at one point that's pretty good no how
many times did you take it all right
then i didn't get that high
yeah eleven's great are you kidding me
no then i'd be the dean of kutztown i
think i got a 980 was all right i was
never good at standardized testing
i was never good at anything where you
had to have
uh a wealth of
past knowledge but anything like a base
yeah yeah anything though that was was
hands-on in the in the moment i was
pretty in front of you that you could
then pretty good at retaining that
information okay yeah
not bad not bad yeah and anything that
was um
uh
you know i studied video production in
college which is one of the reasons i
excelled because anything
i'm good at i'm decent enough at
mechanical figuring that stuff okay
stuff you know like when yeah point a to
point b makes a lot of sense to me did
you have a job when you graduated
college like would you go did you enter
the workforce or did you start doing
comedy
oh no i i play i didn't do comedy for a
while i played music
and i thought that's what i was gonna do
um hold on back that up played music in
what regard you were in a band i started
playing music in the f
fourth grade okay what was your
instrument
well i started playing saxophone at
through the school basically sure you
were in it for the semester or whatever
yeah and i i stuck with that for four
years i didn't like it but i stuck with
it and then in the sixth grade i believe
it was i started rapping
and i did that until i was in college
were you doing were you doing sex rap
no
no
no i i rapped until i was in college and
then when i was in high school i started
playing in like hardcore bands
playing naming your high school band
fancy lads
was my high school band that's a
skateboarding company very successful oh
really yeah there you go hey we found
out it was the name of another band too
but a very different kind of band yeah
yeah yeah uh a lot more eyes that was my
first band
i was in a band before that a cover band
called elmo which i'm not very proud of
but i i have some dear friends that i
was in that band with and then
but the first band band i was in was
called fancy lads you were a hardcore
band and then i is this in college or
did you play it
and where did you did you play around
the philadelphia area were you playing
like the grape street and all that kind
of stuff well when i graduated high
school i left that band and i joined as
a drummer in another band
called um that was called bernie bernie
head flap what's the name of that
[Laughter]
tell me you got pictures of this bernie
bernie head
was dude that's insane it was a wild
name
yeah
yeah oh man how you snickered you're
like we were in a band called elmo and
then you had bernie bernie mudflaps i
like how he asked if he got a job after
college he said i was doing music
no no i wasn't no no
sorry i i wasn't clear
when you asked about i was saying that
to comedy i was doing i was playing
music in these bands right well well not
so let me let me just rewind and what
happened to your right flap was a head
flap was a um indie rock band where it
was a good band and we actually played
um with a couple other bands around
philly that mr jeans
uh no but i remember mr green jeans we
used to play with um
a band called wally who were a speed
metal band we used to play with a band
called bobby cork who were like noise
core we used to play with um
bands that were much heavier than we
were i had no idea about anything uh
yeah i knew he rocked i knew so and then
in doing that band what were you playing
you were drummers playing drums in that
and then i started to write and record
my own music okay
and i started an uh a side band with the
guitar player in that band it was just
the two of us
called salsa windfall
which the reason i bring that up these
are done by like a name generator yeah
it's also well it's like all the
meetings like we need a name that looks
really shitty on a poster
salsa windfall salsa windfall which
is still
hi we're guacamole sir
it's still going they're still going
yeah that's why i bring that up you're
joking really no
no salsa windfall still exists
the taste buds fans found us discovered
us and liked it and they were like we
want more sauce and windfall and i was
like well we have an album we that's
just been on the shelf for five years
we're putting it out i love that yeah
yeah that's awesome you're gonna get
back behind the behind the door behind
the camera that that band is different
that band is me and my buddy paul and we
do everything so it's a lot of
sequencing and and programming so you're
still very much music
uh yeah yeah still in fact i was writing
and recording stuff last night because
we're about to start recording new stuff
like having adjusted this jacket when he
said that yeah
no it's i find it very soothing uh
that's great it's a great hobby um
but anyway
i got out of college
and i was i was rapping i was in a rap
group with my buddy patrick and i
thought we thought that's what we were
gonna do we were like we're gonna do
this like we're these white rappers that
are unlike
any of the other white rappers that are
out there and we have this whole angle
and
we know how to produce beats at this
time who are the other white rappers
like what you like eminem was pretty new
at this point so
and we were very different from that
because we weren't so we weren't like
so was that picture like a tribe called
quest vibe i picture you a big tri
it was more like a cool keith vibe
i picture you guys getting your ass
kicked
down on south street to be honest
with you like your mom pulling up to
pick you up i don't know cool keys
kip let's talk about helix yeah alex
talk about helix you know them you love
them you sleep on one every night you
don't want to spend time in the mattress
store running around with some bozo get
on helix take the quiz two three minutes
find out how you sleep sleep hot sleep
cold sleep light sleep heavy i sleep fat
that's just how i do it
helix will set you up with a nice
mattress right kippy you got one buddy i
got one i think t-bone just bought one
as well
yeah
t-bone
company man i like that keep the money
in the house
twilight locks i was awesome you take
the two-minute quiz i'm a goddamn client
me and the uh me and the lady like i've
said a million times me and the lady
have taken the quiz you got the twilight
bing bang boom lines you right up comes
you zip it open pops up you know you
have it for a couple months and your dog
pees on it it's all things ooh you got
dog pee on your mattress yeah it covers
up the smell for my poop but anywho he
looks awesome but you don't need to take
my word for it he also was awarded
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq on wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com that's garbage
take a two minute sleep quiz match you
with a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life it's my
first grown-up purchase really
king-sized mattress i love it 10-year
warranty you get to try for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up if you
don't love it but i'm telling you you
will you get the kippy stamp of approval
you even have financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away hills is
offering up to 200 off all mattresses
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com garbage that's
heelsleep.com garbage do it yeah okay
let's talk about butcher box put your
box put your box ooh but your butcher
box forget your food
we all love butcher boxes who don't love
butchie bob let me ask you a question
it's the springtime grilling season is
kicking off it's the summer really buddy
i got memorial day weekend let's go
get the grill out man in the grill and
i'm taking down some goddamn butcher box
to the family let me ask you a question
do you want to go to a grocery store and
grab some meat who the [ __ ] knows when
it was packed stand in line with the
rest of the mouth breathers it's
probably not wild it's probably not
grass-fed free range not wild cause it's
made in the lab or do you want to get
fresh grass-fed grass-finished beef
free-range chickens wild-caught yeah
that's what i want you know what i got
if i got a freezer full of it the good
food that's all i'm saying the butcher
box folks send it to us we love it throw
it in the freezer defrost it when you
want it every mob shelf every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high quality meat right to your home uh
free shipping into the continental us no
antibiotics no hormones packed fresh
[ __ ] frozen for convenience you save
time like the big man said high quality
meat hundred percent grass fed free
range the whole nine yards tell them
hank says we're cooking off uh grilling
season with butcher boxes you sign up at
butcherbox.com to receive a free
grilling bundle in your first order a
grilling bundle it's better than ground
beef a gb baby you'll get two 10 ounce
ribeyes five pounds of chicken
drumsticks and a pack of brewers for
free that's what i'm talking about
butcherbox.com ayg to claim this deal do
it now back to the show
it was like it was more like um it was
more like art art wrap okay uh uh or
avant-garde rap which now there's a lot
of and there was also a lot of it
happening at that time i just wasn't
familiar with it
but you had guys like lp and definitive
jux and and uh my buddy
from zarface esoteric and you know these
guys were out there doing it i just
wasn't familiar with them yet
and they were doing
a sort of
an odder approach to hip-hop not that it
doesn't sound like hip-hop but you you i
know what you mean right a little
fringe-esque yeah so um so anyway that
bubble gum [ __ ] you guys are listening
to out there i thought that's what i was
gonna do i maxed out all my credit cards
and bought
yeah and bought um
production equipment
like so i could try to sell i love this
was there any was there any was there
any matching outfits with you and the
other guy rapping
no did you dance at all break dance
anything like that no it was just it was
just
it was we we
our whole thing was we tried to go on
stage as under the radar as possible so
we wear like plaid
shirts and khakis
yeah
like plaid shirts and khakis and and
like and like try to make it look
almost like we were like nerdy like like
sure like skater kids or something and
then drop the hammer on them and then we
could actually rap and then that was
like the thing was like that was our
whole holy [ __ ] so unassuming type thing
yeah yeah so so and we both could
produce beats we both knew how to do it
so i
by the way maxed out my credit cards at
the time was 200 bucks 800 or something
yeah yeah so i bought still my credit
limit by the way
yeah well you're garbage
yeah no but i bought i bought all this
stuff
and i was i was producing
beats and i was trying to sell beats
because i was like that'll be my way
into the music business of course
because i didn't know how to make two
dollars in it and um and at the same
time i was working
uh
hand to god i was working for the senate
in texas
uh texas senate yeah how'd you get down
there i moved down to austin right after
i graduated college so this is all in
austin
yeah the college stuff wasn't the
college stuff was in pennsylvania i
moved down to austin and pat and i were
still in touch that was the rap guy
and um and i was producing
putting beats together and i was uh
wrapping in my
apartment by myself
uh
and then like meeting other musicians in
austin and all this stuff but i was
working as a news reporter for the texas
um senate media
that's a curveball
yeah it was like you were on like the
local new like local austin no no no i
was a senate majority leader yeah yeah
also a dope i was just in charge of the
whip yeah
no it was uh it was
so the senate
uh has its own media department okay
and the job of the people in that
department is to the united states
senator the texas texas okay so it's a
76 legislature session in texas okay
legislative session excuse me in texas
and they have their own media department
and the purpose of that department is to
cover all events that happen on a daily
basis in the senate and then um uh uh
farm those
media pieces out to whoever wants to
show you
conglomerate whoever picks it up so my
job was i was a reporter so this
literally what i would do i'd have to go
from senate event to send an event all
day i have to
take it all in take notes go back write
stories that covered the right one story
that covered the highlights the whole
day
and then do a radio
uh
report on it very caps uh um um
uh
what's concise concise there you go yeah
radio report on it
and this is how long ago it was i then
had to get onto a phone
modem
yeah dialogue yeah and call i don't mean
a dial i mean like there was a [ __ ]
phone like thing where and i had to do
the i had to do this upload okay dial-up
was out there
but
and i had to do this upload
of the report that i did
to this
phone server
that other radio stations around texas
would call
and via their telephone be able to
download
the thing that i had posted and then
they would just run it on their radio
station
as part of their am radio news blog
that's what i would do by the day
i would wake up put on sick beats by
night
yeah yeah yeah yeah in austin texas yeah
there you go
and i i made some lifelong friends doing
that job but i hated it yeah it was not
for that's not what yeah i mean anything
on camera hi this is joe derosa we're
here on the floor of the senate we never
they did not have an on-camera reporter
they had video
they had videographers that recorded
stuff but they didn't have on-camera
reporters i don't know why what about
social events you get to cover that
stuff
like if i had like a benefit or
something i didn't have to cover social
events but i got invited to every social
event nice i got joey rose's i'm not
kidding i got i got like shit-faced at
like
several senators houses that's a good
time like several straight senators
state senators okay but still still bury
a hooker if you need to [ __ ] that was
a 22 year old pothead you know what i
mean it was [ __ ] absurd you guys mind
if i put some tunes on
it was like guys in the album
rap yeah yeah now for the national
anthem
did you uh did you have a producer tag
when you were making beats
a tag yeah like something to stamp that
it was you know like like roses on the
beat or whatever
no my rap name at that time oh boy you
guys will make fun was example
was it spelled funny
no
and i would just say ex
which was kind of cool i guess but like
you know did you ever shoot anybody it
was of the time
yeah you know
it was of the time i get i mean dude
i grew up in bucks county so not too far
away but at that time in junior
everybody wanted to be a rapper yeah it
was like i can't believe any of this i
mean this is really what what i have
kids that are still trying to be rat
like still i was out there obsessed with
rap from third grade forward i just i
loved it it just it grabbed me like
nothing in my life ever has uh
even stand up comedy as much as i love
it and admire it and i'm a lifelong
stand-up comedy fan
uh nothing grabbed me the way that rap
did when i was a kid i don't know what
it was
it was just so
unlike anything i'd ever heard or
witnessed or experienced i get it yeah
and i just wanted to be a part of it so
badly and um
you know you you you go through music
after all those different bands
and uh all those different
configurations and and whatever with
people
you know my biggest thing was i just got
tired of trying to work with other
people i got tired of trying to convince
bookers of
venues where half the time the place was
empty to put my band on that we were
good enough
i got tired of dealing with band mates
and trying to get everybody on the same
page
you know
yeah yeah i bought you the [ __ ] bass
busting my ball you know
uh you just get tired and i just and
that's what attracted me to finally want
to try comedy i went when did you how
old were you started comedy
i remember when the bug bit me i wasn't
i was i didn't start it till i was 22 i
believe so you wait so hold on you did
all this [ __ ] that you just said college
and then year two after college yeah
at 22 you'd been through the senate
[ __ ] nine different bands eight
different genres in the senate when i
was i left this left the senate sorry i
was asked to leave the senate
yeah i went into the private sector
i was yeah i think i was 20
christ almighty man i might have been i
might have been 21
when i stopped working at the same time
yeah i was only there for the session
though okay and it was session seven
eight months i mean it's not like i was
like oh right i got you um so i sent it
big wigs but i i was invited to stay
like i was invited to stay on and be a
part of
the media department it was just wasn't
what i wanted to do in any way shape or
form
that that
that experience was was a life-changing
for me because working in that
environment is what made me lose any
faith i ever possibly would have had in
a legislative system
uh in voting
sure uh
and also the media
that's where it all changed for me and i
never trusted any of those never again
uh any of those entities ever again
um and that was huge for me so do you
ever take any kickbacks to push a story
or anything yeah
yeah yeah yeah make a story go away real
quick
somebody's kid gets a dui i get caught
with coke or something this kid from
philly really plays balls
get roses on the phone bury it
yeah somebody find me example
yeah yeah
get ex
get ex in here sleeping under the road
ah that's [ __ ] why that's a wild tale
all right yeah so
but i was uh i was in college i i didn't
start stand up till i was 22 or 23 but
but i was in college
still rapping and uh and i was working
uh in college i was part of the student
activities board
so i was part of the the the committee
that that got to book events at the
school book de la soul that was pretty
cool that's probably just book yourself
i never booked myself yourself was the
opener for everybody actually wait no i
did do one banned show
that's really good but um but we um we
uh
went to uh we went to it was called naca
it was the conference sure
i've been denied by them a few times
yeah me too
uh and i saw uh they had a spoken word
series at naca and i went and i watched
it and it was people
uh reciting essays
it was like you know
essays about you know it's one
this lady i've seen her since i can't
remember her name she was an older woman
though she's probably in her 60s great
sounds brutal
well that this was just one series there
i like this though i actually and she
did the whole thing everybody's a racist
here's why you know and i really liked
it and i was like that's what i want to
do and then at that same thing i saw
jeff ross live
i thought you were booking these for the
college i run you out of town it isn't
neca no it was i was at naca he was
there i was going to see you have to go
see events so friday night party and
then somebody reciting essays no no not
a party turned up no it's a student
that's not at the frat house it's a
student activities board it's like
things you bring to the school yeah yeah
yeah yeah we have a magician yeah i got
you so you go and you go to neck and you
see bands and you see everything you see
everything right so i saw but i saw jeff
ross and i remember my supervisor or
advisor saying
i said i want to book him and she said
no i didn't think he was funny he was
offensive i was like i want to be that
and i saw this woman who was not a
comedian but was a spoken word performer
who just recited again this this these
essays about racism and i was like and i
want to be that and then i realized oh
my god that's what george carlin is
right i want to be the hybrid of that
comedian
but i didn't do it for years for years
after that but that's when i started
writing comedy fighting the man look at
him
done everything
well yeah it'd be nice if i you know had
anything to show for it
you know got that album coming out you
kidding me salsa windfall coming soon
come see me in ac there you go yeah if
you think that i'd sit down at a mexican
restaurant and they give me two things
of salsa and i'm not calling it a salsa
windfall
that's what the name came from
oh yeah not that exact thing we were
when we when we first started writing
songs together me and paul we were super
[ __ ] up like we were really high and
drunk and we made tacos
and we were on like took a break from
writing and we were making tacos and i
said what should we call the band he was
like salsa windfall there it is we have
a windfall
right now
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah what's your favorite gatorade
what's your flavor
uh red
okay but i love trashy you call it red
yeah but i agree orange red i mean
orange is only orange by color it's not
i mean it tastes like orange sure but i
don't call it orange because it tastes
like orange it's all orange because
that's the color get me a yellow
gatorade
red's king the fruit punch
fruit punch
for the lemonade wake
i do orange for the hangover because it
makes me feel like
i'm like feels different they they play
a different they play it they really
like a different role yeah i'll do red
when i'm sick though oh yeah i get the
molecular lights
yeah when i need like fluids
gang this podcast is sponsored by better
help if you're feeling overwhelmed if
you're feeling run down if you feel like
you gotta talk to somebody at that time
of the year people got a lot of stuff
going on reach out to better help
because they can help if you've got
somebody at work that's driving you
crazy maybe your boss maybe a good
friend of yours you got to get things
off your chest reach out to better help
and you can do it from the privacy of
your own home burnout is a real thing
remember the most important relationship
you have is with yourself you got to
prioritize yourself take care of
yourself
guys therapy has helped me a lot in my
life the big man is gone we're trying to
get him back in
wink wink i'm all screwballs uh but i i
use it at a time in my life it it it was
very very beneficial to just get you
kind of straight align things make you
see things with a different perspective
that we it's a lot living in your head
especially with a head this big you live
in your head
you never see yourself i know i'm
getting lost up here i need that you
move i'm slipping baby better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anybody on camera if you don't want
to but i recommend it because it's
pretty good it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and can be
matched and you can be matched with a
therapist in 48 hours which is huge if
you've never jumped into the therapy
pool it can be you know uh dicey getting
it can be daunting is the word i'm
looking for getting matched with
somebody finding waiting for a call back
then this brutal
getting mash in 48 hours is is a huge
hurdle to over months it takes all you
garbage listeners takes 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp.com garbage
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
do it yeah bespoke post baby
spoke they got that box of us they got
that box so awesome they tell you you're
not in there i could thank you i'm in
the box of cool all right
gang listen it's a summer time upgrade
your outdoor activities upgrade your
summer with a box of awesome whether
it's outdoor gear whether it's stuff for
the bar whether it's grooming supplies
look fresh feel fresh do cool [ __ ] this
summer don't be sitting around in the ac
like a loser watching the simpsons get
out there with a cool pocket knife or
hammock
you guys want to see my hammock
uh no if you want to wow somebody when
you should go off to a barbecue or
somebody comes over
yeah looking real sweet you're gonna
have cool cool guys [ __ ] people where'd
you get that you got this old thing you
play real aloof you know keep them in
the dark because you don't want other
people having your cool [ __ ] box of
awesome takes care of that and the cool
thing is it's emerging brands and small
businesses yes exactly to get started
take the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at about
70 but you pay a fraction of that price
plus with box of awesome like you said
you're supporting small business gotta
love it uh you get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up for box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage you
know it at checkout uh that's box of
awesome.com code garbage 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com code
garbage now back to the back to the show
favorite frozen pizza
i know it's obviously not a go-to you
being uh you know somewhat of a foodie
usually stouffer's french breads
that's a [ __ ] that's the answer
that's
senate money right there god damn sure
french bread supreme is usually you do
one or you do both of them if you're
eating them no you gotta eat both yeah
i don't think two is enough i know yeah
dude i would i would eat [ __ ] four
yeah their packaging is wild too those
things are in like they're like air
sealed nasa sealed yeah
do you prefer a live album over a studio
album
never excellent okay
you're starting to turn it around here
what's the fish tank situation over at
your house i don't have one
would you want to have one
because it sounds like you would if it
didn't take work yeah
but i would never clean it
yeah like that's why i don't have one if
i if it came with somebody that says we
clean it every week too i'd be like
great put it in because they start
getting riped all the smells on those
things yeah it's
at the top yeah what about the pets as a
kid what'd you have
a gray cat that lived in the basement
named dusty
sounds like it came with the house he
said he's picking paid rent yeah he had
the apartment over the garage and then a
poodle named brandy what are your
thoughts on 3d movies
i love the idea of them from the 80s i
love the 80s idea of 3d movies i
remember how exciting that was but will
you go now if it's 3d or regular you're
going to go i go regular because i know
after a while the 3d is either going to
basically wear off because you get used
to it right
the glasses stink yeah or honestly like
sometimes it gets me dizzy good it's not
an enjoyable experience i prefer just a
regular straight up break that's a
classy answer right there uh do you know
how to use chopsticks yes okay
do you have any fireworks in your
apartment right now
no but i have a uh a thing of i have a
drawer of pranks
okay does that count what's the pranks
what's in there fake [ __ ] in a can and
prank jelly beans that tastes terrible
yeah yeah yeah like
a hygienic powder
yeah stink bombs were big back
that would [ __ ] up a hallway yeah i got
some at home smoke bombs
no it's mostly gross out stuff okay yeah
hmm when do you take your shower you
take it at night or you take it in the
morning
neither i take it before i have to leave
you take it right before anything yeah
so before you left you got a fresh
shower yeah okay sometimes it doesn't
stick though when you start sweating
especially in the summer in [ __ ] new
york it's tough
would you start sweating after you
shower oh yeah i know you're right out
of the house yeah you're right you're
right
oh when it's hot when you're getting
ready [ __ ] my hairline doesn't keep
the sweat in anymore yeah
that's brutal i hate when i'm getting
dressed and i'm sweating
you gotta really time it out in a new
york summer yeah i feel like you're in
the army yeah it's tough yeah that's
thanks yeah uh have you ever been to a
bikini car wash
it's tough so you have to think that
hard on that
you know because bikini car washes
though
they're one of those things where i
don't know if i've ever seen one in real
life or it's just i've seen it so many
times in movies i think i've seen it
what t-shirt contest i participated in a
wet t-shirt contest with women
okay
no i didn't the [ __ ]
i participated in a striptease contest
with other men okay and that was not the
original story there's a bunch of hot
chicks never mind naked dudes the joke
was that that that these guys were all
buff it was a daytona uh spring uh break
nice okay and i finally my friends got
they were like you should go in because
your body sucks it'd be so funny and i
won nice did you have to show your
noodles as a performer no you just had
to go down to like your undies okay yeah
what are your undies tidy whites what do
you do
uh briefs strictly breathe old school
brothers colors
i don't know you have to do a low rise
because the high-rise briefs
they're the way they're cut they come up
it they it looks crazy looks like old
yeah it looks insane there's no band no
there's a big band it's just lovers all
right you're wearing
i panties know the band sits i swear to
god
i'm not just saying this there's a song
on right now but the band sits on low
rise like right here where you think it
should okay
it looks insane i should actually look
into that because mine fold over yeah
but uh but i i don't need you and i rise
anything i think jockey is my brand okay
that's not bad jackie's pretty good but
not too you know i've never met like
i have a good channel like a guy your
age young cool like rocking proper
briefs that's all i think it's insane i
think boxers are just for boxers i think
boxer briefs are insane they ride up
your leg the whole time
it's not good for your testicles that
[ __ ] yeah briefs are good support like
they're great keep them snug yeah i'm a
brief guy too
uh good fellows from target black ones i
uh i [ __ ] have fellas yeah because i
have a thing
take a motivated time i have a thing
where i have skyscrapers i refuse to pay
over a certain dollar amount for
underwear good fellows is [ __ ]
fantastic yeah they got a lot of good
[ __ ] over there that they're gonna take
that will you will you take food on a
plane
that's bad but also if you buy it in the
terminal
oh yeah 100 if i buy it in the
tournament like what like a like a snack
or like a meal like you'll buy a burger
[ __ ] shake shack i mean i have no
problem eating before the plane but
sometimes if i have if like i have a
flight at the right time of day
and i see something really good in the
air like like good for the airport like
a jersey mike's just a score in an
airport right so like i'll get two
jersey mic sandwiches and i'll be like
man i got a five hour flight i'm wide
awake i'm gonna sit with these i'm gonna
watch a movie like i get into it i get
excited that's an aggressive hoagie's
aggressive
yeah on a plane you [ __ ] with any of the
food on the plane
well you get the snack box or anything
like that if i'm really hungry but
otherwise no okay
only in a real pinch
you first class guy these days where are
you at
first class what are you nuts
[Laughter]
stupid
[Laughter]
if i had first class money i'd be like
you guys go [ __ ] plug it yeah right
uh you got tsa pre-check yeah yeah yeah
you got it global entry
what's global i don't understand what
global entry is i don't either get you
into like it gets you into the uh
like the eu and stuff like that like you
enter as an e oh it's like pre-check for
over for globe first i don't i don't fly
every season it has the sky miles
you have a brand new i i was very loyal
to delta for a long time but it's all
falling apart at this point i'm all over
the map anymore i got it
put
honestly it's all falling apart i mean
it's they're all everything was good
until we got to the miles
yeah
huh have you ever written a mechanical
bull yes
yes
okay
do you currently have any two dollar
bills
i feel like i might have one in in a in
a box just like a cigar it was my
grandfather's um my grandfather's bach
he had a
i'm
um
to call it a jewelry box i know you kept
this cufflink sure all the guys had that
back in there yeah i have one too like
it's almost like a cigar box sometimes
yeah i have my granddad's whatever it's
called i think there might be a two
dollar bill in there that's in there
because yeah it was his two dollar bill
an old zippo lighter or something like
that yeah yeah cufflinks
or something yeah yeah here's one
you're eating a hamburger
cheeseburger whatever you like
you put it first of all do you cut it in
half when you eat it are you eating it
whole i usually eat it whole unless it's
stupid yeah so when you take a bite of
it
when you put it back down do you put it
upside down or right side right side up
yeah no i keep it the way it's supposed
to be the whole time okay yeah i'm an
upside down guy kippy's upside down
because a lot of times the integrity of
the bottom half of the bun with all the
juice and the cheese and the whatever
isn't there that's right so you gotta
flip it over because then the juices run
and they they get into the that's
upstairs
that's not that's very interesting okay
all right sustains a little more in my
you know just in my personal that's very
interesting that is trashy still though
oh 100
yeah you put inverted burgers over here
that's one of those yeah that's like a
rachel ray trick of course yeah exactly
what's the suit situation at the house
how many suits do you have
you have a suit you can go put on right
now
okay i think i have two
okay designer
one's theory
i don't know what that is
good
good fellows make some
theory yeah it's a high rise
theory's nice nice yeah i just don't
know i also i see theory bloomingdale's
okay okay
all right
the other one is i can't remember the
brand but it's nothing nothing
the theory suit was much more expensive
okay but i've had it forever i'm i'm
probably honestly i'm probably i was
thinking this the other day
i'm about due to go buy two or three new
suits yeah nice great like because i
think the suits i have now are probably
the cut's not right anymore yeah you're
probably gonna show up looking like
you're wearing bell bottoms yeah steve
harvey running around yeah yeah yeah do
you know how to tie a tie i presume okay
wins or not
i don't know what the knot's called but
yeah i know how to tie and i'm also very
familiar with what my friend in texas
were taught me the vicious v
which is when you tie a regular tie
right here under the knot
there should be a dimple yeah that's
called the vicious v okay i'm a prat not
myself gentlemen ladies gentlemen out
there prat not very easy what's up
what's a windsor versus pratt a windsor
is like a heavy bike like it's like a
big it's like a double knot there's like
the double windsor the half windsor
and then i do i do like a real easy
peasy little guy it's loose cause i want
to take it down real quick too when i
get to the [ __ ] reception i go i go
like this over where like this
over wet back up around the back and
down that's probably that's more that's
like a prat that's a little more simpler
okay you know a little more you know all
right it's not as like [ __ ] boardroom
you know what i mean it's like hey i'm
joey roses i'm here to have a [ __ ]
good time i'm a big fan of the shoot of
top button undone tie a little loose
yeah i definitely look at a wedding like
the guy that's got a bag on him yeah and
a two dollar bill to do that to that bag
with i undoubtedly look like that guy at
the wedding what do you usually do at a
wedding um
coke
[Laughter]
jack daniel straight up and a couple
couple key bumps kids all classes in my
book big on shots at weddings big on
getting a lot of people to do shots with
me dancing
uh sometimes i'll dance a little bit but
i'm usually i i
post up i feel like you're a big bar
ziggy guy yeah
do you break the bartender off the
beginning of the night with something
nice keep them in your pocket what i try
to do is i try to tent pull it so like i
try to throw down a 20. early let them
know you're there post
throw in another one coast uh-huh
night if i want something else another
one
you're you're a gentleman in that in
that regards but but i am a big believer
in the balance of if you're getting
hooked up and you spend as much as much
as much money being courteous as you
would have paid there's no point to the
[ __ ] hookup so you got to find your
back the balance so you're going to find
if somebody gives you a free round of
drinks and it would have been 20 bucks
and you now feel obligated to give them
the 20 bucks i give 10. i see what
you're saying you shoot them they want
everybody both
whatever but it's like you still you
still the point of the hookup is you're
getting a little bit of a short course
right
for example of course but um
but wedding i'm big i'm big at
getting
big as big of group of people together
as i can do shots to do shots joe what
do you do gift wise are you a gift or
are you a cash man usually cash what are
we talking i say you're coming to like
one of our weddings
usually for you and you and abroad
you're the
yeah
yeah or a hundred
for the br if i'm so low a hundred for
the bride hundred for the group what
about like a good friend best friend
yeah good friend yeah i might go a
little you know turn it up a bit okay
but yeah i like to go money
what's the most you dropped do you know
i couldn't say but but but i couldn't
say is you wouldn't because you're
classy i couldn't say because you can't
remember because all the coke and booze
you did at the wedding i'm gambling in
that he's going back in the envelope
no i got to say though it's like with if
i was getting married i would want cash
[ __ ] yeah like i want to be able to go
get me what i wanted my house
who these days is going into a marriage
with nothing with no appliances
do you know what i mean yeah who needs
it yeah you don't need a blender for
manchester united 40s yeah it's like i
don't want candlesticks and [ __ ] like i
know
speaking of which if we came over to
your house now
to have a you know a formal dinner not
just you know pizza or whatever how many
people could you feed how many plates
how many forks and spoons well we'd have
to sell my couch first you have to go to
the restaurant you have to go to jelly
roses okay fair enough yeah and you have
to eat off the lift up coffee oh that's
so trashy dude the elevated everything's
a high rise that's my dinner table yeah
that's awesome yeah but how many kids
how many plates do you have of the same
set
oh i only have about four plates because
i know the basic setting i have a nice
little apartment but it is not meant for
a dinner party okay i did want to say we
saw you probably the last time we saw
you was uh at an event like a dinner
event a food event at a comedy at the
stand
and that was fun uh shout out to uh the
food freak 100 um he uh i made a lot of
awkward eye contact with joe we didn't
we didn't really know each other i kept
on catching your eye and be like this
guy thinks i'm a psycho yeah but you did
i didn't show her i didn't even notice
he lost that's how much of a bozo you
are yeah
he looks didn't even know he should
start on him he was on his ninth glass
of red wine i was keeping count yeah no
but yeah you make you make you you
really make that night i saw you in a
different light you looked very
cool like you just looked very at home
you had the glass of red wine he's good
in a restaurant
you were moving he's good in a
restaurant you're going out for a ziggy
or what it was just like it was very
fluid it was i was like holy [ __ ] you
look good you look good
it goes out well i'm big on uh i like i
like uh i like long meals yeah that's
why you were in it yeah yeah he's good
with a half a glass of wine in his hand
something else though it was very very
you executed it very well wines yeah i
like wine desserts for the table
individual desserts what do you what do
you think's appropriate i'm f i'm
individual everything really i mean i'm
i'll do it i'll share app apps and
whatever okay i don't hate it i'll share
apps as long as we're getting our own
entrees i hate when people want to share
through the whole meal i don't i don't
like sharing entrepreneurs i don't even
like doing what about getting an extra
entree or two that everybody could pick
at that's fine okay but i'm saying like
i you know there's i want to i want to
work on my own thing over here we can
share an app
or a couple apps i'm not against i'm not
against sharing desserts but do you
normally do dessert
not usually uh i did it the other week
with my parents for their anniversary
what'd you get
well and i shared my dad and i my mom
wanted this coconut cake and my dad and
i wanted we got cheesecake and chocolate
cake and shared it because i couldn't
decide where was this where were we at
we were in jersey okay steakhouse yeah
nice yeah it was all right
yeah
right you like an espresso at the end of
the meal
uh i do with uh especially if we've been
drinking did you throw down for your
parents uh dinner
did i pay for it yeah yeah
yes how's it going that was my gift
today that was again nice yeah yeah
how's the how's it go if you wanna you
know you and a buddy go out
and you can see it's just you two you go
out to dinner
who's picking up the chat how are you
doing are you splitting it it depends on
who it is that's who it is
i mean i'm from with you guys i'll be
like let me get this
and get you a warm place to stay for
tonight
no no but i'm usually uh like i remove
you know remove comedy it's you and a
buddy you know remove any comedy dynamic
or you know if you're going out one of
the heavy hitters you're expecting them
to pick up the check right i don't ever
expect it's be like
you're the best
let's put this away i'll have less if
i'm out with sal i'll have less guilt if
he picks the checkup okay cool but i
don't expect him to sure sure you know
what i mean but is there a slight
difference in the ordering maybe if
you're pretty sure no no no no no
because he has it it's not like he can't
cover the third glass sure no i i
there's no in fact when i know
somebody's gonna get power pull back a
little bit i pull back and in fact i
think that's a that's a sign of garbage
because you're not you feel it's it's
impostor syndrome of course you're
afraid that you will somehow overstep
yes of course of course yeah because you
have that power dynamic in yeah we make
the power dynamic in our head like oh
this is like
it's not there it's just your body's
like yeah let's go out to dinner i'll
pick up the check but it is the classy
thing to do to not over order the person
that's paid let's say you go out to
listen whatever you guys want i'm taking
care of it it is to over indulge billy
let me get three surfing turfs that's
garbage yeah to pull to just to not over
order the the host i think it's classy
but there is a psychology involved in
that being garbage i understand what
you're saying but there was also too la
and i i joke about sal i break his balls
all the time about
his success sure
uh even when sal
goes to pick up the i fight him on it
like i don't i just don't i've never
really felt very comfortable with that
and i and i probably
i and i don't say this to pat myself on
the back i say it to say that i'm
garbage
uh i probably overly push
to be like let me give you some money of
course like i'm the guy i'm the
equivalent of the guy i'm cool with it
give me a call yeah i'll equivalent the
guy that's like do you want gas money
and you're like what are you talking
about you know what i mean like so if
you bump a cigarette on the street
you a dollar guy i force them you gotta
offer the dollar i force them to take
the dollar and i say
i don't smoke anymore but when i did i i
would say
i understand where you're coming from i
understand what this
it will make me feel better so just take
it and then they would go all right
because that's just like this is for me
it's not for you yeah
screaming
well you know and especially in this
city the cost of those things i mean
i would get i honestly excuse me when i
no dude they're like they're i think
they're like 20 now i get them from the
i get them from the
bodega by my place it's ten bucks out of
state oh really yeah that's great it's
all the way downtown though yeah but in
jersey have you ever waited in line for
a midnight premiere of a movie yes
yeah i saw all three
uh star wars prequels at midnight oh
here we go again
those are the three i waited in line for
i mean i had two kids i had tickets but
that was back when you had i had to wait
in line to get the tickets and then i
had to wait in line because that was
before you could reserve your seat
hey give me please ask that question
again should you dress up at all no
no who's the chewbacca with the glasses
yeah yeah
eating a peanut butter and chip sandwich
no pushing his mixtape on everybody
no i never
that's the weird thing too like i love
cons i love going to horror cons and
comic-con i love going to video game
cons
or something you're a cool dude but a
nerd
good dress-up [ __ ] sure of course do you
go with friends or solo because i feel
like you're very comfortable with
yourself usually solo really i usually
have a pretty hard time finding people
that want to go to that sort of thing
with me
yeah don't ask me yeah
so i'm going han solo to the store
all right this felt so bad for you right
there
it's not like those of my family and
friends don't speak to me yeah
but there's a there's a level of class
in that being able to go to things like
of course by yourself it's not making
dinner by yourself is classy dope it's
not but it's like going to those things
solo it's not like sad like oh i'm going
so it's like i'm gonna go to this thing
for four hours
i will be left alone
and i will go at my own speed through
this bog down you never go and stay over
like get a hotel no no no no if i was
going to do that then i would
i would find somebody somebody to go did
you ever make friends at one of these
things and like hang out with them
uh no
i've seen friends i've run into friends
randomly okay i ran into jerry roach at
one uh
you know jerry you should have called me
yeah yeah
we could have went together yeah
parking alone and i met a dealer at one
like a like a game dealer
this guy's getting coke at comic-con
he uh he knew me
he was like a fan okay and he actually
helped me because you can trade your
stuff at these things i brought it he
helped me sell a dream sega dreamcast
that i brought
which was very cool um but i also have
friends that have been
i'll take your word for it
yeah i just got a nintendo switch though
and i [ __ ] love it it's great it was
actually toby's christmas present
who's toby oh toby toby sorry sorry
that's i'm just staying in i just met
you today i know yeah of course oh we
met a couple times
but you said you said i showed you the
dreamcast
man you said last time we saw i saw you
you didn't even talk to me that's true
you stared at him oh that in the stand
thing i didn't know this [ __ ] it's oh it
was only because all of our interactions
have been like [ __ ] housed at skankfest
oh well well then that's why i didn't
remember you
come on cut me some slack here
sorry i had to throw you under the bus
the timing was too perfect yeah i know
so i'm sorry
now that was so in
perfect the fabric of the show it's
great i'm terrible with it
how many pillows are you using over
there
i have four on my bed at all times you
got a king or a queen
uh uh jumbo queen i think it is okay
that's all right that's good queen is
the standard for an adult moving forward
is it in the corner oh it might just be
a regular queen it's fine i don't know
it's in the middle of the room or in the
corner
uh middle okay classy kind of sheets are
on there please don't say star wars
no solid color shoes okay i don't
remember the brand nice decent thread
what do you sleep in
uh i usually sleep in
uh shorts or underwear okay no shirt
not usually so i get hot at night
sometimes i'll sleep uh pajama pants
t-shirt on top of the covers this guy's
bonkers oh that's
serial killer sleeping on top of the
cover sometimes i'll be in the mood for
that and i'll i'll get like a fan breeze
on me that i don't mind no not not a
sheet or a blanket or nothing but if you
can time it right where it's not cold
you're not going to get cold and you
just get wow i get that because it feels
like that's how the boogeyman gets you
but i fall asleep
if i do that i'm going to sleep to to
i always go to sleep to tv or something
see the tv i want to go to school it
just feels like
it kind of just feels like you're
passing out in the middle of the day
sure sure you know it doesn't do you
fall asleep with your glasses on no
you take them off does anybody do that
that's crazy just straight sleeping in
them i only got two more here um how do
you pronounce the word
the product
uh
produced by crayola
a crayola oh crayon crayon mm-hmm that's
right there you go instead of what
crowns i say crowns he says crayon you
say crayons
i might sound a big i might say that if
i wasn't thinking about it i don't know
yeah okay
slurpy or icy
slurpee i mean those slurpees king
slurpee is the coca-cola of slurpees
okay what was the vacation situation
when you were a kid what did you guys
just go to shore pretty straight forward
well
oh it's got a cramp in the neck wow
oh wow i thought he was setting up a bit
i'm sorry no this kid's wild you okay
yeah wow we're sleeping like a vampire
lose the pillows and get under the
covers will you
holy [ __ ] i catch those two
um i feel like he's looking around to
steal something he's got that wandering
a trade show for your boba fett
i got a dealer you want to move that
yeah no i uh uh we didn't go every year
we sometimes couldn't afford a summer
vacation when we did go was pretty
simple our big one was disney world when
i was very young big that's great not
bad but yeah that but that was that was
it what's very young how young were you
you remember third third grade wow
that's great perfect age um my last one
i got say you're going you know to uh a
friend's place a sal
or whatever and having dinner like you
know we're having people over dinner or
whatever are you going with a gift
like a bottle of wine or something and
if something so
i try to not show up empty-handed and if
i do i'm very apologetic about it uh i
don't like showing up places
empty-handed do you have like a goat do
you ever have you ever tried to like wow
somebody with the gift you know like oh
or somebody even though he's like a big
wine guy or something you know
yeah kind of just be like i'll just give
him give me the 19 bottle and we'll keep
it moving i remember back we were um
when i was when i was doing opium
anthony
uh pretty frequently anthony invited me
to his house for his big he had this
like legendary
fourth of july party or something it was
some holiday
summer i think it was fourth of july
and i i like finally got the invite and
i went to the store and i bought like
i don't know a thirty dollar bottle of
wine like something that for me at the
time was a flex very expensive yeah
and i freak out when i walk in yeah and
i brought it and i was like oh this is
gonna knock his socks off this guy
drinks like budweiser's like this is
come on like he's gonna beat this is so
nice and i brought it in and as i walked
into the kitchen where he was to say hi
and handed to him he was literally
standing in front of a wine cellar ah
that was just stacked
like one of those electric sure whatever
and i was like and i just go
i thought this would have been cool but
who cares i would have your own and he
was like laughing at me but he was like
no it's great man like sorry he was like
trying to keep a face off was it in a
dog's bowl yeah yeah
but yeah i remember that like being a
time that i thought like i'm gonna i'm
really cause that you do get reached
that point especially in comedy when
you're like oh i can i finally i finally
have a couple of bucks i'm not living so
poor and you're like i want to try to be
an adult that i haven't been able to be
for so long yeah and you try to flex
first time you brought a 30 rack instead
of a sixer yeah exactly but i mean
that's the tough thing man is is i have
always had and continue to have
and will continue to have
uh
many friends in this business that have
reached financial heights that i have
not
and might never uh quite frankly uh and
i'm okay with that i've come to terms
with it but
it's tough sometimes because you want to
bring something you know i'm not i'm not
talking out of school here it's like
it's like when i lived in l.a we all
know that burr is very successful
obviously
and he's doing all right yeah as well
he's he's a pretty down-to-earth guy
when it comes to his tastes and things
like that he's not materialistic but
he's done very well for himself so it's
like you'd go i'd go to his house for
something and it was very hard to figure
out what do you bring because
well would you you know
i would end up just bringing honestly
like a bottle of scotch or something
like that okay and and and it and trust
me when i say it never mattered a bit
yeah at all
but
it's it's a tough thing to figure out
when you know it's an easy
you know it's not too expensive you get
a nice dessert
yeah the the popular donut shop the
cupcake shop oh hey we went by melissa's
yeah that's a good one yeah got a thing
of cupcake what was the um cause it's
more of like functional than like even
if you showed
yeah like a bakery that isn't everywhere
yeah hey we did this or even if you
showed up with like four boxes of krispy
kremes it would be a little kitschy it's
like fun hey we're slumming it joey's
great i got 40 big macs hey you know
what was a big hit that i did i went to
um
i went to uh brian quinn from
impractical jokers i went to his house
for a party
and i showed up with
uh
a
hundred airplane bottles of jameson
that's fine you go how'd you get your
hands on them i went and [ __ ] bought
them whoa let me tell you that's a real
expensive way to buy jameson
but i show you a hundred
[Music]
i've cleaned out both stores
that's fun that's kitschy that's good
and it was a big it was a big [ __ ]
hit oh man i might steal that that's
great because because uh that was one
thing where i was like
again like i'm not like
those guys are very successful you want
to show up with something and nobody
would give a [ __ ] none of them would
ever care sure but you still want to
show up with something you don't want to
feel like you feel like it's some kind
of contribution just give me your call
you know you show up with roles
i got a case amorosos in the trunk you
know i don't know i don't know i get in
my head about that but maybe that means
i'm garbage i don't know i love it
ladies and gentlemen mr joe derosa joey
thank you so much thanks guys sandwich
shop mm-hmm check out the live streams
joederosainfo.com
for live dates and tickets and uh
joeyrosesnyc.com for the sandwich shop
info
and yeah podcast taste buds and we'll
see you in hell they're both out there
thank you buddy you're the best this was
so much fun appreciate it
what do you got for him just uh we're
gonna be on the road we're announcing a
bunch more dates uh we currently have
buffalo detroit and
pittsburgh on sale get those tickets why
they're still available and uh yeah
appreciate all support gang gang we love
you we'll see you next week peace